cha-ching it is money time week one
betting show let's go let go let go I'm
gonna make you let go of your title this
year you're going down kid four years in
a row
I've beaten sin I think it's only three
I think it's three cuz I only the first
year we did the better right we did not
but we went out for a lot and it's okay
I just let you go that so guys yeah no
you're right it's three I'm going for
going for the four you're going for but
let me just say audience there's a
disclaimer I don't feel good about my
picks this week oh gosh oh I don't know
what to do emoji the fact that I'm in my
head in it's week one I am screwed week
one's hard though let me get this out of
the way first shout-out to a yahoo
against spending money with us are you
ready again judge me one through ten
okay yeah I'm gonna try and do this
surprise surprise yeah are you ready for
a live football on your phone with the
Yahoo Sports mobile app you got it watch
local and get out of here primetime NFL
games on your phone or tablet not just
this week but all season long I mean
never miss your local game never miss a
big-time national matchup wow wow
all you need is the Yahoo Sports app
it's just get it get get the yahoo
sports app and you're golden
do it already geez how was that that was
pretty good I was genuinely surprised
I mean Yahoo I mean hey they got this
internet thing kind of figured out first
off want to say this to everybody that
watched the show Wednesday night
Thursday Friday on YouTube Simpson left
go the show I really want to appreciate
it appreciate you guys to see all the
comments section and to see all the
people telling us that wow you guys are
blowing up or you're glowing up right
now we're so proud of you
like I want you guys to know that all of
this is happening legitimately because
of you guys we would go in there and
we'd say all the time look we have this
audience they really support us we think
that we're kind of this cool community
and we love them and they love us and
for you
guys to show up and just fill it with
all that stuff whether it was Twitter
Instagram but really in the youtube
comment section
it was awesome to watch and I know we
had fun making we definitely did it
feels right it feels like us it feels
like podcasts but yet we got some pizazz
with an a little sizzle and I also think
to all the people that were like we're
the podcasts dude we got you
so we'll just to kind of go over
everything Tuesday Wednesday Thursday
Friday we have a new something for you
every day
Tuesday we're recapping the weekend
Wednesday night is gonna be the show
Thursday is gonna be diving into
simpson's notebook and friday will be
this show which is betting on all the
games like we always have so you guys
are getting more from us this year
because if you took any of those things
away I think we'd be pissed I agree
because it's something that we like to
do that if you took it away be like well
when are we diving in the sims's
notebook when are we previewing the game
is what are we looking back and the show
is like next week we got a lot more
stuff yeah Sean McVeigh is gonna be on
the show right
D'Angelo Hall's gonna be on the show the
show will be great and again I
appreciate all you guys for watching it
yeah thanks everybody
it is funny we had ray liotta on the
show and then your wife went on a date
that's right I know hey we pulled some
strings so here's how the gambling
podcast is going to work me and Sims
will get a bankroll of sixteen hundred
bleacher bucks each week every week
every week no matter over the bye week
or anything cuz it's $100 per game would
you so no it doesn't matter in the bye
weeks I'm stupid $100 per game stupid
sorry
yeah so in the bye week we get less yes
yes but it's it's $100 per each game the
minimum bet if you don't want to bet a
lot is $10 per game can so you could
legitimately bet fourteen hundred and
fifty dollars on one game and then bet
ten dollars on the other 15 if you
wanted to right if you did that in week
one I'd call you crazy
so pendrick is going to keep track of
all this when we make the bets there
will be graphics on the bottom of the
screen and we will keep track and see
who's winning who's losing one thing
that we noticed from you guys
last year is you guys thought it was
hilarious when we would bet on the
Thursday night football game and you'd
message us after the game already
happened and go it's so funny to hear
you guys bet on a game that already
happened and realized that you're
completely wrong right so what we're
gonna try and do this year to kind of
grow that is we're gonna instead of
doing a preview of Thursday night we're
gonna do a pre cap this is a challenge
to us it's definitely a challenge to me
we have to talk about the Thursday night
game like it's already happened since
everyone's here in this Friday morning
we're gonna kind of make our picks and
be like I totally knew the Falcons we're
gonna win that game that I mean look big
Matt Ryan threw three interceptions
we're gonna try and do it like it's
already happened okay though we're
recording this on Thursday this is bound
to be screwed up by me we're gonna have
one mascot battle each week and I think
we'll find ones where we completely
disagree on the game you know I'm ready
to battle cool and so we'll do one
mascot battle and I've done some self
scouting I listened to the season
preview episode okay and I realized
towards the end not only did I interrupt
you a lot I took a lot of your
information I have heard for the better
part of four years that I interrupt
Simms a lot and what's crazy is I don't
even know anymore
yes and I didn't know either and then I
went back and listened and went I'm
annoyed by myself so here's what we're
going to do since I naturally listen to
your bets and then take my own opinion
from that you're gonna go first
okay people really don't listen for me
they really listen for you well you're
you are better at the betting let's
let's let that out there I don't feel
confident this week but what my idea is
you're going to you're gonna do the bets
I'm going to shut the F up you're gonna
do it and then I'm gonna go goddamn it
yeah I was completely opposite of you so
I'm gonna let you go first I'll go and
then at the end we're still doing
guaranteed to lose which I'm very
excited right okay first but then I'm
acting like this happened are we going
to Thursday right I'll get that so we
are gonna be doing Sims what happened
last night in it yeah Anna Philadelphia
where did you put your money well first
of all we gotta remind everybody that
the bets are locked in we've already
done this before the show we're not
making this up on the fly or anything so
we're already locked into what we've
done just so everybody knows out there
okay
the Philadelphia Atlanta Falcons game
last night was phenomenal it was a great
game it was great but I got a little
false confidence there early on because
Eagles and Nick Foles actually looked
pretty good and I said whoa okay this
looks like the Nick Foles from the Super
Bowl but then as the game went on
we saw the Nick Foles that we kind of
saw all preseason and late last regular
season we were questioning them I think
a lot of our evaluations before the game
we're kind of correct we were concerned
that the Eagles doesn't have weapons on
the wide receiver yeah with no Jeffrey
there and Mac Hollins who I think is the
go deep vertical guy right and that
really hurt the Eagles I think overall
in their game played hurt the rpoS left
go because I think the Falcons will
separate of it what are you afraid of
we'll play man-to-man we'll get in your
face will do saleh the game you saw that
in the game too right yeah so that was
that was very tough sledding for the
Eagles the theme of the Eagles hey the
offense being inconsistent from the
preseason it carried over to last night
and hey the Falcons won I mean there's
nothing we can do about now we went out
the game it's 2023 220 Falcons win the
football game right and then how much
money did you put on the Falcon I put
$200 on the Falcons yes I had the other
thing that I think came to for was $200
on the Falcon they can kill Eagles they
come from the top
your dad Eagle like that house great yes
but I think the other concern I had
about the Eagles going into the matchup
is the nickel cornerback situation right
I got Annie Jones Avante Madden right
who's that gonna be who can they rely on
now that Patrick Robertson's gone and
through my studies during that week
going back and evaluating Atlanta from
last year one thing that jumped out to
me about the game first of all they were
horrible I'm third down so I thought
they would have some wrinkle in the red
zone and in the red zone so I thought
man if there's one thing they got to be
better at this offseason or at least
have a few tricks up their sleeve for
this matchup that it'll be third down
and red zone on offense and it proved
right last night they scored a few
touchdowns they were better on third
down okay but the other thing I think
they had to look at and this is where I
think Calvin Ridley came into play
they must have came to the end of the
season last year and just said damn we
we only really have two options in the
past game we need another guy if Matt
Ryan's gonna be our guy and I really
think that they went into the game gone
we're gonna test this third corner for
the Philadelphia Eagles they exposed
that well and that's why the Falcons won
the football game that's interesting yes
all right so 2325 in yes so I don't know
what game you were watching I'm gonna be
honest I have spent the last month
telling everybody and their mom that the
Falcons are gonna win this game and in
the beginning of the game I was going I
was right I'm watching the game and all
the the banner reveal from the Eagles
all that emotion Falcons went down that
first drive and they did what I was
really worried about right which was
they attacked the absence of Nigel
Branham yes I do like Jordan Hicks yeah
I don't know what I'm getting with him
coming back coming back fast rusty yeah
also you know they don't have Michael
Krenz excite us crew drew Hill guy he
kind of was a little rough friend uruk's
and courage or he'll I don't know their
names I stop interrupting I didn't there
are a few but I they really focused a
lot on Devonta Freeman Tevin Coleman
kind of attacking the middle but what
happened was a lot what happened in that
playoff game this time though it didn't
require the ball going off key on
O'Neal's knee instead of relying on Nick
Foles I think the unit that everyone
forgot about was maybe that the
Eagles had the best offensive line the
NFL when they're all healthy and I saw a
downhill running game last night
that I really wasn't expecting Jaya Jaya
the legs look good Corey Clement looked
really good and to see Darren Sproles
dice up a great linebacker like they
have in Atlanta Falcons and catch that
touchdown was very impressed how much
did you bet who did you bet on I well
luckily with the Eagles winning the game
I actually bet a hundred dollars on the
Philadelphia Eagles oh my god alright so
let me go through now I can smell me be
normal now that's been okay and that was
hard it's hard enough being me I'm not
that smart so here's the first thing
right I looked back because I kept going
oh well the Patriots blue a home game
that happens all the time yeah in the
last 15 years right
this Thursday night game has been won by
the home team how many times do you
think it lasts 15 years oh I often top
am i I'm gonna say about this old won by
the home team or the same team oh I'm
gonna say it's probably twelve thirteen
Wow so other than last year right that
would be 12 of the last 14 no that would
be thirteen the last fourteen years
before last year the home team has won
never has another defending Super Bowl
champion opened in primetime at home
with the same quarterback that won the
Super Bowl and be favored by anything
less than three point five points is the
first time it's happened
Wow they're always the other loss if you
don't mind me asking you I have it I
just okay I didn't look alright like
that I want to say like the Cowboys lost
of the Giants it was the opening of the
new stadium I think it was the Giants
lost to the Cowboys because the Cowboys
haven't won a Superbowl no but I think
the Giants went to the Cowboys after
they won the Super Ball the whole team
and they lost I think but maybe I'm
wrong I'll have to check it out all
right but what really went into my head
was this is an Eagles team that won the
Super Bowl and is being treated like the
underdog yet again I think often what
happens to the Super Bowl champion as
they go out there and there
they're too excited they're too happy
they're they're taking it light
maybe it's because I'm just so into the
Eagles that I'm hearing all these
stories about how motivated they are I
look at the Eagles defensive line and I
think they've been a little
underwhelming thus far in the preseason
but I expect against a Falcons offensive
line which is a little bit smaller I
think they're gonna be all over that
running game the other thing is we're
just assuming that Steve Sarkisian is
gonna have it I can tell you I hear you
I am and I look at this offense and I do
think they're gonna have success in
their first drive my Falcons but I look
at the Eagles and go I look at a Falcons
d-line if this if Eagles offensive lines
clickin they can push around all those
guys Grady Jarrett will slip through a
few times but I really think they can
get a big push right on some of the
small they're a fast team and the Eagles
are a big team
I just I'm glad you brought this up so
just remind me to go back I'm gonna just
wrap it up like this I just thought I'm
getting a home team right on Thursday
Night Football with a very good defense
and and I think Matt Ryan is like one in
four in Philadelphia where he's from
right I look at it and go I'm gonna take
practically a home underdog it feels
like by the by the time this game goes
it might be an underdog yeah I'm gonna
take the points because I think the
energy is gonna be crazy it will be and
I think we're under estimating the two
lines for the Eagles yeah because Holly
pulleys not playing no it's Peters no I
know you got you have salt I think I'll
take that yeah I get you you get the
better line on both sides of the ball
there's no doubt about that that's where
I when the Sarkisian thing is very real
we don't know we're hoping we're hoping
they're better on third down we're
hoping they're better in the red zone I
will say this just the context of last
year right you know that it's I was
thinking Falcons no no and I know I know
you're not wrong because the context of
last year too I think people need to
remember this the Eagles kind of
dominated the divisional playoff game
babe okay they kind of pushed Alaina
scored ten points on after Jaya Jaya is
fumble on the first drive twin got down
a field goal and their other touchdown
drive was an 18 yard drive off the
muffed punt if you remember that's how
Elena scored ten points
Eagles had their way they made it ugly
they beat him up up front yes uh but
still Matt Ryan had the ball I know on
the six yard line like a minute
to win the game yeah and I think the
other thing this is my last thing we'll
move on is just the context of last
season - let's not forget the Falcons
had to play a pretty physical game the
week before your team had two weeks off
really play no games of meaning I - and
we're as fresh as could be at the end of
the regular season where the Falcons
were had to play Carolinas in the New
Orleans at the end of the year to
actually get into the playoffs let alone
then go to LA yeah so those are little
things where I said I think the Falcons
are gonna be a little more fresh and
have a few more tricks up their sleeve
schematically I I totally in my head
yeah I think the Falcons are gonna win
but I I think that I looked at this and
went this just feels like an Eagles win
to me that's the weird thing with
betting man like I'm gonna be honest I
took a lot of risks this week yeah I
also spread my money
practically even across the board okay I
learned from last season yeah that
there's things that happen in week one
that don't replicate themselves Buck's
beat the Falcons two years ago Jim
Tomsula first year the Niners beat the
Vikings and then went on to lose the
next seven games
it's a fluky week and so I took a little
bit of risk but I spread my money out
because last year I got screwed one
thing before we get into the one o'clock
games for Sunday I went and looked last
year the one o'clock games in week one
away teams were six and - Wow at one
o'clock interesting at four o'clock
Sunday night and Monday night home team
home teams were five and one I've always
believed that some teams get shocked at
one o'clock the four o'clock Sunday
night and Monday night games watch that
and go let's not get shocked is that a
thing that football player it can happen
I think it can happen it's definitely
those guys are opened up to the idea of
like wait this team was supposed to win
in there being upset we better like get
on our P's and Q's here the other thing
is the schedule of the preseason
everybody played night games and now you
have to play it one o'clock we notice
there's only a few teams that play like
1 p.m. preseason games yes
very few very
now sunny Buffalo right Cincinnati
Buffalo the Rams I think did it two or
three times though their starters but
exactly so I think that's what gets them
to as they go wait wait I gotta be like
ready to go at 12:30 in the afternoon I
haven't had to do that all year and I
think that's what kind of catches teams
like that by surprise I just thought
that was very interested is very
especially so that's why I took a little
bit more risks - all right so first game
I feel like I know where both of us are
going on this yeah
Buffalo at Baltimore and we're getting
the line at minus-7 I'll set it up
Buffalo will be starting Nathan Peterman
yeah I think people saw that Cincinnati
game and it scared everybody because
that offensive line we are both very
high on Baltimore I have them one in the
division you have them going to a wild
card how do you see this one play it out
well I certainly think the Baltimore is
the better football team here they're
favored by seven points and I think
that's a little too rich for my blood
first of all yeah I do I'm putting $10
on the Buffalo let me just make sure
that way hold on oh I'm wrong I'm wrong
around $10 on the Baltimore Ravens all
it's right in front of me I know but I
have it here there's some other things
jumbled in here okay so don't worry
about my notes used to worry about your
notes so you're doing $10 on The Rave
I'm doing $10 on the Ravens here yeah I
don't feel necessarily totally confident
that they can win a football game by
more than seven points I need to see
this offense a real time action Shawn
McDermott said very good defensive
coordinator he sit right in front of the
deef exactly right he's gonna be very
smart and taking away some of the things
we've seen the Ravens do offensively and
I think they can maybe make this what
scares me is just I think they can maybe
make this a little bit of an ugly
defensive struggle type of football game
where I just don't know if the Ravens
win by four points or maybe they win by
10 points I could see it either way
I clearly think the Ravens are the
better team but week one does always
scare me like you kind of said yeah and
this is just one game where I looked at
and just said I'm not so sure there's a
few too many ifs there for me and I'm
going with the Baltimore Ravens $10 so I
looked at this and I thought the one
Baltimore weakness that I see on defense
is May
be the secondary with Jimmy Smith being
out and it's the one thing that I'm not
afraid of Buffalo taking advantage of I
looked at this and I thought I figured
that line would be bigger and I felt
like Vegas because they know the Ravens
like we know the Ravens and how they can
under perform and keep teams very close
I looked at that and went that line
should have been 10 but they went
Baltimore doesn't squirrel on they made
it seven
I put $200 on the Ravens - 7 the Ravens
are coming Sean McDonough I thought this
this is really Wi-Fi go if I'm gonna be
this high on the Ravens yeah and I'm
gonna give him the two seat I loved how
they came out last year 20 des nothing
to win like 10 turnovers in the first
two games
I love the Ravens special teams and I
know that Buffalo keeps teams in front
of them yes they were a lot better at
home last year and I look at Baltimore
and I go I think they're gonna come out
and they're gonna make a statement that
that's kind of how I look at that okay I
think the offensive line is healthy I
think the Buffalo defense is good and I
know they got star luteal a Lee but I
think overall their defensive line isn't
that impressive no it is I don't I don't
see like I don't think Jerry Hughes is
that guy it's a lot of good nothing
great and the the Buffalo Bills were
very reliant on turnovers last year yeah
I expect Alex Collins to have a very big
game I think the Baltimore front 7 is
going to be able to stop the the LeSean
McCoy and the Buffalo Bills running
things though yeah create a lot of
pressure on their own yeah I think the
guy that everyone's forgetting about
that could end up being a star in this
game is Brandon Williams
I think Brandon's gonna be in the
backfield a lot I I think I see
Baltimore winning this game by 13 points
okay that's kind of how I see it yeah
that's I mean I feel I feel or I share
your feelings with Baltimore I just I
got to see them I gotta see the offense
in action I I do I just worry about ugly
games that which is the style they play
if this game was in Buffalo right I
would have done what you did you would
have done what I did because I think
Buffalo in Buffalo for some reason I
really we're I think we're gonna learn a
lot whether it's are we under estimating
Shawn McDermott's ability to keep every
game closed or is this team gonna fall
off like we think it could yeah it's
certainly one of the least impressive
rosters in the sport I think from top to
bottom as far as difference-makers
that's that's the thing we look at but
the one thing I always loved about
McDermott is his team plays as a whole
the offense balances the defense Brian
day ball being there coming from New
England I do think he'll know how to
handle Baltimore a little bit to where
he could have a few things just to slow
down the pass rush or the aggressiveness
but I'm with you the Ravens are gonna
win this football game yes I just don't
have that ton of confidence you have
more than me now I'm rooting for Buffalo
to keep it close that's also good yeah I
really came down to this I could see a
lot of sacks on Peterman like we talked
about Joe Wright and then with the
Ravens ability to pin people deep with
that great punter and Justin Tucker's
ability to kind of pound it through from
everywhere I could see them pile up a
few points and I really love the Ravens
that's really what it's all good all
right next one probably the game that
I'll be having my eyes on the most for
one o'clock Jacksonville at the New York
Giants I'll break this down there is no
team in sims's mind that is more
athletically gifted than the
Jacksonville Jaguars and you believe
that the New York Giants could have a
great team they really do when you look
at their roster they're loaded all over
the place the question is which team
pulls it out Simms
go for it yeah I'm okay so Jacksonville
State Rice throw my bets out or my
reasoning first I guess that's what I
should ask you do you want me to throw
my bed out right off the top just to
tell you where I'm going here
what do you like better my reasoning
doing the reasoning first okay all right
so here the biggest thing is this
Jacksonville yes in my estimation is
clearly the most physically gifted team
in the sport I will say that and you
mentioned it the Giants are very
physically gifted as well the one area
that I would question the New York
Giants in a little bit is their
secondary and to what you kind of said
about another matchup a few minutes ago
I don't think that the Jacksonville
Jaguars have the type of offense to take
advantage of that bortles is not that
kind of a thrower that dynamic too
where they can maybe expose an Eli Apple
because Eli Apple is going to be like
enemy number one all year long every
team is gonna go we need to test Eli
Apple out early and see if he's on this
P's and Q's and if not then we're gonna
continue to attack him now the physical
battle up front yes clearly Jacksonville
is the better team up front on both
sides of the ball but it's not by a lot
the New York Giants they're our
offensive line it's a solid group I'm
not gonna say that's world beaters but I
think with the new offense and patch
Shermer the more Man Man scheme blocking
schemes in the run game where they pull
guards and do things like that I do
think that's gonna give an advantage to
the New York Giants at least for is
slowing Jacksonville down from just
pinning their ears back and attacking
all the time let alone Shermer is very
good at play action pass he's very good
at screens
oh yeah and Seco on Berkeley and Odell
Beckham jr. out there and they are freak
shows so when I look at all those things
I go okay New York Giants can hang in
there with the Jacksonville Jaguars but
at the end of the day the Jacksonville
Jaguars still are amazing and super
talented on both sides of the ball I
don't feel super confident about this
the Jacksonville Jaguars are favored by
three points I'm going to take the
Jacksonville Jaguars for $10 I'm going
what made you go with them uh that I
just need to see this Giants offense and
really number one I need to see that I
you like Manning hang in there and play
in this type of game against this type
of defense like Eli throwing a ball and
turning away and not wanting to get hit
against this team if he's gonna do that
then they're gonna lose by 20 but if
he's willing to stand in there and
there's a good little game plan to
protect them and Shermer does some
creative things we know Jacksonville
doesn't play a whole lot of different
defenses yes and if they can find some
little tricks up their sleeve as far as
just exposing this scheme like we saw
Jimmy Garoppolo do or the Pittsburgh
Steelers or the Patriots do degree yeah
I think the Giants can have some success
there but I got to see it first to
believe
totally that's why I go $10 on the Jags
one thing that really scares me for the
Giants is that Olivier Vernon is still
bad I think and right brain and it's
it's interesting it's like I want a guy
that can get after the quarterback but
in a weird way I'm okay if Blake bortles
is sitting back there patting the ball
and I want him to kind of throw it right
um I'm gonna tell you right now that I'm
I write down my first thought and then I
look into it and then I write who I'm
gonna pick
good my first thought was Jacksonville
yeah and then I looked at the line if
you're minus three on the road that
means you're supposed to be six points
better than a team on a neutral site
yeah
and I thought about that yeah first
thing I looked at is we got a new DC for
the New York Giants
James Boettcher how did Jacksonville do
against James better last year not that
good I would argue that it was the worst
offensive game for the Jaguars possibly
all season it was up there he held for
net 225 yards rushing and I think this D
lines better than that deal I do I agree
and they they were able to put bortles
in really tough situations then I
thought about Shermer okay Shermer is
gonna he faced Atlanta's offense last
year it was one of the Vikings worst
performances fourteen points against a
similar cover three type of scheme this
is what I think the game comes down to
when Jacksonville won the sack margin
last year by two or more they were eight
and one when they lost it by two or more
they were one or two if Jacksonville
gets after the Giants and which I think
they can we're gonna learn about will
Hernandez er we're gonna learn about
Erik flowers at right tag Nate's older
Nate's older yeah how much attack is Eli
in yeah I though believe that with
better at DC and with Shermer on offense
they're gonna screen the the
Jacksonville Jaguars to death I think
it's gonna be a lot of counters and in
my head I thought this could say Kwan
pop off a 60 yard run yes yes could OD
el pop off a 60 yard run out to the
catch yes right then I need Jacksonville
to score 14 points I had Jacksonville
down as my pick and then I went back and
I changed
I'm going the Giants $50 plus three okay
to cover the spread here right it's
another instance where I go I'm gonna
have to be rooting for Blake bortles
against a sound defense I could see
Landon Collins all over the place I
could see Alec Ogletree pop and Leonard
fournette 1 or 2 times I I think that
Jacksonville wins this game but I think
they win it like 2120 and that's why I'm
picking the Giants Plus time I think
that's why I didn't bet money because
yeah I could see it being that way
that's it I mean exactly or I can see
Eli throwing to pick sixes and also
scary I just think that Eli is gonna
come out and protect the ball the guy
that I think has the biggest game that
if I'm doing daily fantasy I'm focusing
on Evan Engram no doubt I think the one
position that Jacksonville allows points
to is the tight end position and I think
I think schirmer's gonna come out with
all of the bag of tricks and when I
heard Doug Marrone say I want Blake
bortles to throw zero interceptions this
year I thought they're coming into this
game going let's not make mistakes
they're gonna just try and run the ball
the whole game yeah and I think that the
Giants are gonna come in with a lot of
wrinkles yeah and I think Jacksonville
comes in cocky and Giants come in
looking to prove something match up with
in the matchup but let's move on I mean
Jalen verse Odell oh my gosh Myles Jack
forsake one oh my god that's the two
things I'm doing I think wins those two
men oh my gosh I'm gonna go with Myles
Jack and Odell even though I don't think
I'm Myles Jack as you know we've noted I
think is primed to be the best
linebacker in the sport he really is he
had from what he did to the end of last
year and what I've seen this preseason
he's the best there is
yeah Jalen Ramsey's the best there is
but not to say that Odell is always
gonna get his way with Jalen Ramsey
offensive coordinators can find ways to
cheat themselves this day and age it's
not longer the era of Deion Sanders
we're like Jerry Rice lines up on the
outside and Deion gets to go against
them in the same spot every time
no they're gonna find ways that excited
to see Jalen come across formations make
life hard on them with pie action passes
crosses things like that it'll be
interest I can't wait that's definitely
my number one watch of the of the
weekend
Tampa Bay at New Orleans we're getting
the
New Orleans favored by nine and a half
we're going down to New Orleans
give me some pizzazz give me through
Jesus looking to kick the bugs ass New
Orleans is one of your Superbowl pick
yes Tampa Bay is one of the teams that
we expect to really not have a great
year right especially because Ryan
Fitzpatrick is playing the first four
games the first three first three games
of the year
Sims give us some of your analysis and
then your pick I think some of my
analysis is this okay
the New Orleans Saints are the they're
my cream of the crop in the NFC they're
one of the best teams in the sport we
know about their offensive line how
talented they are I think it's one of
the best own lines in the sport in the
conversation with the Cowboys and your
Eagles and the Ravens and those type of
teams the Jacksonville Jaguars they're
in that conversation as well but the
Saints ol line is special and we know
what Sean Payton can bring to the table
as far as game planning things like that
also I got a look on that that flipside
of that matchup and go now this is a
different Tampa Bay defense there's some
size and physicality up front right now
with some of the additions they made
we're not gonna have buy to be it
doesn't sound like so that stinks but
you're gonna have Vinny curry and Bo
Allen exactly right JP pees on the edge
they just hooked up the coral massive
national Browns exactly right yep you
got two athletic middle lime checkers
McCoy and Gerald McCoy don't overlook
the best guy on the deal I know the best
maybe the best player on their team so I
look at that and go okay but I do think
that's a formidable forefront for De
where the New Orleans Saints are not
gonna have their way oddly enough the
Saints always struggled down there in
Tampa it's a New Orleans oh I'm wrong
then sorry about that
that's changes my thoughts thinking a
little bit does change my four year talk
about the heat I was totally going to
talk into the dome that's in a dome we
don't have to worry about that that's
okay
other way to change your bet on no I'm
not I'm not gonna change it I don't I
don't feel any different about it but
either way well so then we flip side to
the other side the New Orleans Saints I
really like their defense I'm not gonna
say I love it like I don't expect it to
be top five in football but I think it's
a top ten to 12
type of defense um I don't know if
there's they need another
difference-maker and you've heard me say
that and hoping that could be Devon I
hope that's gonna be Davenport but he's
really just getting into the mix and I
don't I mean yes exactly right we're
gonna see because the buck so line there
are question marks learns in ten there's
no there's no doubt about that but I
have like some things I've seen out of
the Bucks offense in the preseason so
where you go and they do have weapons on
that side of the ball yes come in to
Sean Jackson Mike Evans just because
it's a weak one and nobody's counting
them in I'm doing $10 in the Bucks it's
nine and a half points Yoho Yoho the
pirate's life for me yes I just do I
just think it's one of these games where
I'm human emotion will play into this I
think the New Orleans Saints are
probably looking at this and going we
should win this football game there's no
Jameis Winston and I think that the Bucs
keep this game a hair closer than people
would think Sean Payton versus Mike
Smith's defense the last two years
mm-hmm at home two years ago he dropped
31 right at home last year he dropped 30
right so lost though right they lost
they won at the end of the year last
year they lost in Tampa oh yeah forget
forget it's in New Orleans
yes I've really met Brian Fitzpatrick
played the second half of that game
because that was the diving into the
back of a player like Evans game Jameis
Winston so Ryan Fitzpatrick did play
threw a touchdown but it was really all
chimera in that game I thought that this
was gonna be my crazy pick it's not
I'm putting $50.00 on Tampa Bay yeah
here's why yeah 2014 the Saints started
Owen to 2015 the Saints started Owen 3
2016 the Saints started Owen 3 2017 the
Saint started Owen - if there's one team
that's coming in maybe a little cocky
and always falls flat early on
it's the Saints and if there's one guy
that I think might actually stumble and
surprise people I'm kind of thinking
it's kamar
he has to he has to be the entire load I
went back and watched that game in New
Orleans against Tampa Bay Ingram had a
few big time runs in the second half
right Kimora's gonna have to be that guy
I think it's chimera the entire game I
think New Orleans wins this game I don't
think they lose this game yeah but darn
near 10 points might be too much that's
what I think I don't know how Ryan
Fitzpatrick is gonna take advantage of
things like that's the fear but the
d-line of the Bucs is the reason why I
go they might be able to drop seven guys
and without a doubt things are loud up
all those quick flaps for four points I
didn't make that I wish I would have
made and you did so that was great is
the drew Brees is a slow starter there's
no doubt about that
you see I I do I always thought like it
takes him a week of sort of slow against
the Vikings I know and really week two
against them they played the New England
Patriots last year right I got here in
front of me that was the same type of
thing so that took I think starters and
then I think the Bucs secondary has a
little more talent than years past their
life chances are I can't believe you
agree with me this will be the key to
the game and this is what you guys
should want D dollars you didn't fifty
dollars in the second quarter last year
outside of the two games in which the
Bucs played backup quarterbacks they
were outscored in second quarters last
year 121 to 31 Wow
if the Bucks can withstand a second
quarter rush I think they're gonna be in
this game again I think the Saints win
but I think the Bucks keep it close
can't believe we agreed on that we agree
one of the games week one is you have to
take into account that people are
hearing the same thing about the same
team and a theme over so good they're a
Superbowl ride you guys can't go in New
Orleans and beat them with Ryan
Fitzpatrick though this place is gonna
match that's why I thought about that's
why you see crazy one o'clock start the
games like you said exactly this was
arguably one of the games of the year
last year deshaun Watson went into
Foxborough put up 30 points and it took
a hell of a Tom Brady Drive to march
down the field and he hit Brandon cooks
in the end zone to win the game it was
another one of the
deshaun Watson coming-out parties
Houston at New England the Patriots are
favored by six and a half Billa Brian
has yet to beat his coach they got beat
27 and nothing with Jacoby percent they
lost 27 to 10 and then they were out
dueled last year Simms your analysis in
your pick for Texans at Patriots I think
the Texans are gonna be a much improved
football team just from the health
standpoint alone I'm expecting a
different football team without a doubt
I think I look at it from this this
other angle to let's just take about the
Houston Texans versus the New England
Patriots defense the New England
Patriots front seven is going to be
better than she is and we still have
questions about the Texans o-line okay
so there's things I need to see they're
added with the fact that I don't think -
Shaun Watson's gonna be running around
the same way he did last year up in New
England I still think it's early on in
his recovery he's looked good but I
haven't seen him make those like amazing
escaping the pocket type plays yet and I
don't think we're gonna see that for a
few more weeks so that plays into my
decision but we talked about the
Patriots front 7 being better yes that's
better but what's not better is their
secondary that does scare me a little
bit they don't have that other guy New
England likes to play man-to-man and
then they can do other creative things
with the rest of their secondary whether
that's past the backs off to certain
linebackers or safeties you don't think
that McCord Ian Gilmore enough I I don't
I don't I do not I Devin McCourty yes no
I do not I would not trust Devin
McCourty anywhere on the same level as a
Malcom Butler oh yeah I know they're not
the same guy now Cobalt ler is still in
the conversation for top 10 corner in
the sport that's a huge loss for this
team and for this scheme that the
Patriots like to play and uh you know
hey will fuller being in the back in the
bunch he can run by people we know
deshaun Watson could throw the deep ball
well Ellington looks better the
Ellington is gonna be the key that's
where I was going he had a huge game
last year in this one cute and he had a
huge preseason and you could tell he is
now featured in this Bill O'Brien
offense as in like the Julian Edelman
role and I've liked the way Lamar Miller
looks as well now flipping it over just
real quick hey the Patriots they're a
little lack of weapons on the offensive
side of the ball
I don't think I'm terribly concerned
about that nor am i terribly concerned
with their offensive line even though I
know maybe it's not as good and the
Texans are coming with JJ and everybody
else but damn I worked there ok and I
worked there when we played the Texans
and they were 10 - no 1 year that bill
and Josh are gonna have 9 million
different ways to slow down that past
Russ passion rush with certain screens
hurry up offense first game of the year
I would think New England does a lot of
hurry up offense to wear down that front
seven and make things interesting there
I think the Texans keep this game close
but I don't feel necessarily confident
about it I'm putting $10 on the Texans
because I could also see this game being
a three-point lead for the Patriots late
in the fourth quarter and they go down
and shove one more in the end zone and
they win 10th by 10 and that's where I
get a little concerned oh just too many
s for me to put big money on it when I
watch the Tom Brady Drive against the
Eagles I I go that's what they're gonna
do against the Texans 3-step drop ball
out of the hand Jadeveon Clowney whitney
merciless JJ Watt your strength is
completely neutral yes I do think
however though that they're gonna get a
lot of pressure right up the gut
the Patriots I think are gonna be in a
lot of tight end running back heavy sets
and they're gonna be doing it with
double tight ends or James White and Rex
Burkhead in the backfield I have the
Houston Texans covering for $100 so we
agree again here I think that six and a
half is too big I see this as a
three-point line in my mind I am very
high on the Texans I had them going to
the Superbowl sure I think that the
Shaun Watson comes out here and I I
think that he's gonna put on a little
bit of a show I hope so I think that
that the the patriots defensive line is
impressive but I'm curious how they're
gonna handle the rpoS that they're gonna
get sure Lamar Miller right my my backup
tight end
Jordan Aikens they were ok releasing
Stephen Anderson I'm hoping he catches a
touchdown because I'd love to gloat
about that I I think that again the
Patriots win this game but six and a
half was too much for me yeah
I saw this and I know that a lot of
times when you win you often cover I
think the Patriots are sometimes slow
starters as well mm-hmm and I'm very
interested to see Tyrann Mathieu back
there I thought that a lot of your
analysis was good I don't really want to
go too much on that but I see the Texans
keeping this game close and and I think
six and a half is just too much yeah I
think we have the same thought there
I just couldn't Bo you had 50 or 100
hundred okay I'm telling you I went
hundred on almost every game boring yeah
I'm trying to play it safe I'm trying to
win yeah you're trying to entertain me
no no I'm not I'm trying to wear circles
gonna whoop your ass this year I'm just
telling you okay because I didn't have
to do an article yesterday and do it pre
I got to sit down last night and not be
married to scores that I've already
thrown out there and digested it you are
[ __ ] dead de dee dead thus far we've
agreed on Baltimore Tampa and Houston
and we've disagreed on a Philadelphia
Atlanta and Jacksonville New York Giants
even though I know in your heart of
hearts you wanted to pick the Giants I I
did I just couldn't do it I couldn't do
it yeah and that's good I can't believe
it but the Eagles I mean I just can't
believe oh you know what sometimes you
gotta be a family San Francisco at
Minnesota Jimmy G and Kyle Shanahan take
a high-powered offense - their star free
agent acquisition running back into
Minnesota to take on a team that has
superbowl aspirations a great defense
and a new quarterback in Kirk Cousins
the Minnesota Vikings are favored by six
and a half Chris Sims are you going with
or against your favorite coach of the
NFL okay so here we go let's take that
49ers offense where's that Vikings
defense that Vikings defense is special
okay it's it's only second to the
Jacksonville Jaguars and my estimation
as far as D line linebackers secondary I
mean that's studs all over the board
they're there they're just unbelievable
and they added Sheldon Richardson and
got a Mike Hughes at the end of the
first round whose I thought was one of
the best rookie corner in the draft
class so they've added a little help
there now it's week one I'm
man when I want to have to play Kyle
Shanahan in week one
it's just his Zimmer said that yeah yeah
who did he say that I'll fill it okay
cool because Kyle is a magic man and if
he has too much time to sit there and
study a team he is gonna screw up the
rules of your defense now it's funny you
just said that because I would think
Zimmer would know that too and we'd go I
got to do a few things different that he
can't get a beat on me because if Kyle
has a beat on you I don't care if you're
the 85 Bears you're in trouble and so I
play off that now okay
the 49ers old-line is definitely better
definitely definitely it's really very
impressive Tomlinson Richburg Ornette
yep we got our guy McGlinchey a right
tackle a kid a little instant good
that's what I say yes I yes to all of
them so it's it's a good group and I do
think they're gonna be able to run the
ball to a degree but come on Sims but
yes the 49ers the issue is their defense
they're gonna that's the big problem
they're gonna move the ball in Minnesota
I think people expect but I don't think
moving enough to go we can think 30
points out of the San Francisco 49ers
this week on the road and Jimmy G's like
this is his real start of his career
here this is now this is now like we've
paid you like you're the man and you're
taking us on the road to Minnesota the
bright lights are on him and everybody's
gonna be expecting things but either way
the other side is what concerns me like
you said no Rubin Foster no Rubin Foster
on a defense that's just not that
talented to begin with and now they have
to prepare for an offense that they
don't really know what it's gonna look
like a job developer Randy Filippo new
quarterback and the biggest concern with
Minnesota on their whole football team
is their offensive line yes and the
49ers don't have the defensive line to
really take advantage of that in my in
my in my estimation I could see them
slowing down the running game right so
when all said and done Minnesota's gonna
win this football game but I'm putting
$10 on the San Francisco 49ers
I think they keep like I kept coming
back to like 30 24 30 27 Minnesota type
of win that kind of thing there so that
was my two cents all right let me get
into some of this Shanahan versus Zimmer
I don't
why how I missed this Zimmer just kind
of came out and said unfortunately I've
had to play them a few times and I
really know how good he is but here's
how the matchups went four times since
2008 they faced the results Shanahan's
offense has averaged 26 points 390 yards
and if his quarterbacks have thrown nine
touchdowns three interceptions and have
a passer rating of 109 point nine yeah
2009 Shanahan was the OC for the Texans
Zimmer had the fourth ranked defense and
he allowed season highs and first downs
yards in Houston beat Cincinnati 28 17
2012
Kyle's now with Washington Zimmer has
the 6th ranked defense with Cincinnati
they allowed a season high of 31 first
downs and Cincinnati hung on to a 3831
win whew in their last meeting however
Vikings head coach his defense carried
Minnesota to a 20 to 10 win over Atlanta
I think that was Kyle's first year when
I was the OC right I am putting $100 on
Minnesota to win this game and cover the
six and a half canons yes
um different kind of cannon so how they
have two different kinds so that's the
one we will eat your bones and drink
more blood all right I look at the
Viking how much money to put in a
hundred okay too tight the rest of them
are gonna be huh okay okay so don't get
excited okay your bets are crazy mine
are very simple I look at the Vikings
and I exactly what you said they can't
take advantage and I will say that the
Niners offense has looked good but can
you also admit that Jimmy Garoppolo has
kind of been like he hasn't been
comfortable in the pocket in any of the
preseason years yes and I go that's some
dicey moment I go okay so they're gonna
want to go deep to marquise Goodwin the
Vikings have like two or three corners
that can run with him I really believe
yes they do I also go you're gonna have
a running game with
out a big-time threat like Alfred Morris
can get it done and I know the fantasy
community is super excited he's not
Jerick McKinnon oh he's not at all he's
getting u6 and that's why didn't you
hear what Kyle said yesterday at his
press conference he just said that was a
huge blow to his whole scheme because
he's been orchestrating everything
around Jericho versatility yeah and
Alfred can't catch and breed us not
really healthy yet George Kittles not
really healthy yet but I look at the
Kirk Cousins offense and I see digs and
I see Phelan and I see Kyle Rudolph and
I see Dalvin cook and latavius Murray
and I think that I I don't think the
Niners been able to score every single
time down the field and I think
Minnesota's defense is gonna be all over
the place I could see Minnesota winning
this game by 10 but Kyle putting a few
wrinkles in there we were like man Kyle
had a few but that's what scares me
yeah but I have $100 on Minnesota it's
the better team at home and I think the
Niners are gonna have a bottom 10
defense in the NFL this year and I think
Kirk Cousins is gonna come out slinging
yeah that's what I see cool so we
disagree there disagree I'm happy that
we disagree let's go fighting Kyle
Shanahan's Tennessee at Miami Tennessee
Tennessee comes in one and a half point
favorites on the road we have been
questioning Marcus mariota's ability
thus far not his ability the way he's
been playing thus far
Jack Conklin is coming back Miami a lot
of question marks we're getting Ryan
Tannehill coming back new offensive line
new offensive center for the Miami
Dolphins new pass rusher for the
Dolphins but the Dolphins are one and a
half point home dogs Simms where you go
in here well this is a big thing for you
this isn't it's not a big one I did put
a little change on this okay okay so
here's my my two cents on this matchup
the Tennessee Titans had we know that
they're a good running football team
certainly yes I do worry about the way
their offense looked in the preseason
not just Mary Marcus Mariota but I just
don't know what what it's quite good
be it's been such a run heavy football
team and I know Matloff or is gonna
bring bring more creativity to it and
get you know like we saw taewon Taylor
called a screen pass took at 50 yards
those little things like that will be
implemented into this offense but I
think the big thing that scares me more
than anything for the Tennessee Titans
Marcus mariota's play was not just like
concerning it was bad in the preseason
it was bad be ad bad okay
and I think this Dolphins defense has a
little more talent than people are
trying to let on Minka Fitzpatrick is
avian haired rashon Jones Rashad Jones
this yordan Phillips exactly right you
got drama deli in the middle and this is
where I'm going Robert Quinn cam wake
yes um the first round pick Harris yes
Charles Harris no Jack Conklin on the
other edge of they're waiting to see if
he plays yes okay so we don't know you
don't know but either way I don't think
I'll be at his best and I'm not
necessarily in love with the interior
part of that offensive line and the
Tennessee Titans either I look at the
Miami Dolphins and go
yeah there's question marks about their
old line but I don't look at this
Tennessee Titans as like the monsters of
the Midway that they're gonna steamroll
them you keep going up yeah it's alright
sorry I know you want to interrupt but
that's cool so then yeah I looked at
that also with the fact that you know
Miami's got like little more weapons I
think than people are talking about my
ears hurt I know I know but they have
Kenny Stills and Albert Wilson Amendola
John Drake and Oh awesome right Gorda
going to Seki exactly so those are the
little things I look at that I think a
lot of people are sleeping on the
dolphin I think we're both going
dolphins here we are gonna go I think
going to office I'm going dolphins for
$100 I think dolphins are gonna win the
game outright I don't know what Mike
Vrabel defense is gonna be I know it's I
appease that I'm so disappointed that
you didn't do a dolphin them I am just
too deep into it give it to me again
you're from Tennessee you can't swim
I'm gonna hit you with my fin you're
laying lock you're going down you're
talking though about I don't remember
yeah well no I just and the Miami
Dolphins are one of those teams in the
AFC that I look at and go there's a few
games on their schedule where they
can just come out on top in the fourth
quarter they might be back in this
playoffs at 10 and 6 or a 9 and 7 like
they were 2 years ago when they went up
to Pittsburgh and lost in that wild-card
game so I think people are sleeping on
them and I think they know it and you
got to go down to Miami and it's gonna
be hot as hell and that's where I go
fence I love that the game is in Miami I
love that there's gonna be Heat Miami
earlier in the year is a trap torture
also what if they go out in Miami you
know that's a thing - it is sometimes
they go out we're gonna go to that South
Beach you just have a dinner Miami is
the team that I am higher than most
people on mmm Tennessee is the team I
think I'm lower than most people yeah I
think that the big guy in this game is
Jordan Phillips I think that we leave
this game and people go in Dom akin who
Jordan Phillips is out there making a
mess of the Titans interior offensive
line yeah I really like the pieces that
they have I think they have an offensive
line that if you really look at it it's
got a lot of Road dogs it does it's got
a lot of Adam GaSe type of guys that
just want a they want to annihilate you
I heard on some other podcast people go
and they lost the core of their team
Jarvis Landry and Dhamma can sue we
would argue they took the team back
exact I look at the offensive line
Larrin how on so tell a fleet right josh
sitting very successful player for both
the Bears and the pack right Daniel
Kilgore not a pouncing on a fancy solid
offensive it was athletic which is why
he's was in Atlanta I mean not in
Atlanta but with 49ers in Shanahan
because he can get to the second level
and do those I'm not the biggest Jesse
Davis fan sure I am a fan of JaJuan
James at right tackle right were
first-round pick in his athleticism
mmm I think the heat I think that they
come out there and I think if I look at
the Tennessee Titans they are a team
that got worse this offseason yeah their
secondary is a lot better with Malcom
Butler but they lost both of their
interior linebackers and the guy that
they they drafted to replace them the
linebacker at Alabama out of Alabama has
not played it all you know has not
played it all yet their defensive line I
think has gotten a little bit older I
think that Kenyon
Raik has a big game i think the Dolphins
win this game outright I'm putting a
hundred dollars on the Miami Dolphin all
right we're in it together welcome to
Miami
uh IIIi think this is one of those games
where I like Miami as a better team I do
too
I feel more confident about it what I
like is all those receivers we talked
about it kind of negates the really good
corners that the Titans have a Dori
Jackson Malcom Butler Logan Ryan I see
the dolphins and I'm gays doing a ton of
bunch formation I think so they take
wills out and it we're gonna be crossing
right so you're not gonna we're not
trying to go deep with Devante Parker I
just see a lot of confusion in the
middle and I think the Dolphins come out
here and shock a lot of people yank one
I'm with you man all right that might
have to be a left go lock for me I I
like your thought process I mean I think
we're on to something there so we'll see
so thus far in terms of left Calaca j--
i might go tennessee in miami yeah and I
think I'm leaning towards Baltimore okay
those are two teams that I like
season-long I think yeah I think those
are safe I mean I got no problem making
Tampa Bay I'm not making Houston I'm not
making Minnesota because Kyle I'm not
mad at you for the Baltimore one I I
hear you very good I was very stuck in
that one all right now we're gonna do
this is another line that I found to be
interesting Cincinnati at the Colts
there's no van tez perfect he is out
we're going to see Andrew Luck holy moly
yeah new revamped offensive line with
Braden Smith and Quintin Nelson the
Cincinnati Bengals come in got a lot of
weapons all over the place but no
surprise a lot of people are down on
them I'm down on them too I don't know
what kind of offense we're gonna get
from Bill laser but we know that they
have athletes Sims the Colts are favored
at home by three where are you going how
much money okay all right so the first
thing just to make this clear clearly
the more gifted team on the field is
going to be the Cincinnati Bengals like
not even close not even close I would
argue that the Colts have truly they
have one of the worst rosters in the
sport right now
and the places where they're good at
their young so they're not even
experienced there yet either and I'm
trying to hate on the Colts cuz I a huge
believer and what they've done they
could have a better quarterback you
don't have a better quarterback and when
he's an Indianapolis he is scary okay -
I hope exactly right but I don't think
so because damn the Bengals got cover
corners okay that are bigger and just as
fastest team yes they do and the Bengals
defense is extremely talented their
front four is extremely talented now I
do think the Colts will may be able to
be able to rely on a run game a hair
more than years past but I don't think
this is gonna be a well-oiled machine or
anything like that to this point so I
just look at the Colts and go I gotta
think there's gonna be extra attention
on the T Y Hilton matchup from the
Cincinnati Bengals or where does the
rest of the offense gonna come in the
pass game well we don't know but I would
assume with Frank Reich it's gonna be
Jack Doyle and Eric eibar and no doubt
the tight end is gonna be a bigger focus
but I'm not gonna sit here and hang my
hat on Jack Doyle or Eric Ebron at this
point I need to see a little more
evidence then I sheffster Roger then I
flip over the match other side and
you're right about the Bengals there's
no there's nothing there's no like mo -
their offense what are they what do you
do what when it's third and four what's
your go-to what do you what is what do I
know that you are where's the fiber of
your team they don't have that but they
don't need that against the calls they
don't need it
the Colts D line I just don't have a
whole lot of faith in that not only in a
stop to run but also applying pressure
off the edge
I think the scheme of the Colts defense
is pretty simple - to where it's a week
that the Bengals talent I think can just
shine through and overcome their lack of
a good scheme now their old line the
Bengals is not special I know that but
damn we know the cold steel on it that
especially they're getting after the
quarterback for that call I know there's
nobody that you can hang your hat on at
this point and I just think from that
standpoint I'm going $100 on the Bengals
only a hundred I do think that the
better football team but of course
Andrew Luck does scare me at home that's
the thing that's what scares me and his
ability just to make big throws but
since it's his first game back in real
live action four quarter football play
I'm gonna say he's a hair off
game and not the same guy we quite saw I
am also going 100 dollars on the Bengals
I - I - the fact that Anthony Costanzo
is still banged on the left tackle for
the Colts and a backup offensive lineman
Denzel Goods banged up - they need all
of those guys to protect Andrew Luck I
believe that the Bengals defense is
gonna be coming on that turf Carl Lawson
Geno Atkins
Andrew Billings they're gonna be pushing
the pocket back and I think Andrew Luck
and I don't know who he's throwing -
yeah I think that's the big the big
question also I don't know who's running
the ball Jordan Wilkins has had a little
bit of a fumbling problem thus far
Marlin Mack is banged up he might not
even guy that that'll be huge cuz Marlin
match I do think is a pretty solid
running back my thing though was which
corner is running with AJ green like
their corners right now it's so
underwhelming and Nate Hairston Kenny
Moore pierdes ear and Quincy will side
now who is going step for step they're
gonna need to put Malik Hooker over AJ
Green the entire time and then who's rid
of John Ross no I think that this though
ends up being a Joe Mixon game because I
just think that he's gonna get out there
and they're gonna want to show their new
peace guy I also have been very excited
at the health of the tight end for the
Cincinnati Bengals and the fact that
he's coming back and looking good help
me with his name Eifert yes thank you
Tyler Eifert came out yesterday and said
I think my injuries been a little bit
overblown apparently in the red zone
Tyler Eifert is being used strictly as a
receiver they're not asking him to block
I don't I think that in the end of the
year we end up more impressed with the
Colts run and the city Bengals season
but I think in week 1 with a new coach
I like Marvin Lewis going in there and
getting a straight up win I expected the
Bengals to be favored in this game by -
yeah and then when I saw the Colts were
favored by three I said this is the
worst roster in the NFL with a
quarterback that hasn't played in a year
I'm gonna take the Bengals even though I
don't like Andy don't yeah I'm with you
all the way so hundred dollars on the
Bengals and I think that is my third
left cone off you think you go there
well what game are we going with next
well before we get to that Sims can I
ask everybody a quick question I asked
you in the beginning of the show
did you follow through did you go and
get that Yahoo Sports I did Noba lap you
got it you did are you ready for live
football on your phone well with the
Yahoo Sports mobile app you get live
local and primetime NFL games all season
long never miss your local game never
miss a big national matchup all you need
is the Yahoo Sports app it chops it
flips it cuts and it cleans your kitchen
seriously go get the app it's your
ticket to watching live NFL games
whatever you wherever you want it's all
football and it's all yours it comes in
handy I'll just tell you watch live NFL
games on the Yahoo Sports mobile you're
gonna have to do some sort of work on a
Sunday and you're gonna go damn that
games on and you're gonna be happy that
you got the Yahoo app on your your
iPhone oh we're going to a wedding
awful let me watch this during the
ceremony what yes this is something that
I could have been done in May that you
wanted to save money just where you
going
all right now it's to a game that has a
lot of storylines attached Pittsburgh at
Cleveland Pittsburgh is favored by three
and a half since we did our podcast
yesterday the offensive line of the
Steelers has tore into Le'Veon Bell yeah
David to Castro just sit out the whole
year then mark Pouncy a star is born
every year in the NFL did anyone know
Kareem hunt would be an all-pro if James
Connor didn't have cancer he'd be a
first rounder just watch him Ramon
Foster what do you do here's a guy who
doesn't give a damn I guess so we'll
treat it as such I just hate it came to
this he's making seven times what I make
twice as much as Villanueva and were the
guys that do it for him I mean have you
ever heard teammates talk about a guy
like this they're mad I know I can't say
that I've heard teammates come out on a
star play he must I think there's two
there's a lot of unknown yeah let's just
call the subject I do think that the
Steelers players probably have a pretty
good inkling of what he's being offered
and they're going damn he's turning that
down that's crazy okay I also
think the Steelers players are going
damn like we have a chance to win the
Superbowl and it sounds like he had
probably told them he was going to be
back at some weight point this week I
don't think Marquis counts he comes out
on Monday and says what he says he kind
of put his name on unless he feels like
oh no he's kind of told me all along
that he's gonna be there for week one
let alone that his agents been saying
things like agent talk about was they
just say gonna have one of his best
years ever all those things so I would
expect him to come back I will say this
if he comes back this is not gonna be an
issue those linemen are gonna be able to
look him straight in the face and go
yeah dude I mean like we want to win the
Super Bowl
like there's it's not like personal
against you but we got to worry about us
and you're not here with us and you're
not with us does this rally the team or
does this divide that it rallies the
team yeah I was thinking and I also
think let's just dive into this a little
levy on bail I can see his side of the
story to to a degree
okay just from the side of the like the
simple fact of he doesn't want to go
there and be worked into the ground
which he sounds like there's a concern
there and that they're gonna give him
340 carries and another you know hundred
and something targets in the past game
and then his career is shortened by this
and Pittsburgh goes oh oh we don't care
what about on the Freak raise your
market we're done with you but I also
will say that I do think loving on bail
is being unrealistic and what he's
asking for but you cannot get a new
contract yes it's not about money I know
you're right it's not about nothing can
happen nothing it's about whether or not
he plays all 16 I've set out for I think
you're right it has nothing to do that
to it and the guarantee like the
guaranteed the Steelers have a
guaranteed money issue like they don't
seem to want to give teams players
guaranteed money even look what they
gave me Oh Antonio Brown it wasn't very
impressive guaranteed money else so
either way I don't think it's gonna
affect the Pittsburgh Steelers we got
change you mind how long let if when
your teammates come out and say all
these things
does that make levian go I'm gonna sit
out more or you know what I better get
back he might know I think he might say
like f you guys now actually push on the
other one I do I think it could yeah
just evaluating the guy and who we've
seen yeah I do I was shocked to hear a
Pouncy go after him because I've been in
Pittsburgh and seen Pouncy and loving
about their boys yeah I mean their boys
through Miami go so I
that's where I look at it and go uh but
um okay so now let's get back to the
game Pittsburgh Cleveland I don't think
it's a huge like drop-off if they don't
have Lobby on bail teams can survive
without stars I mean that's we just saw
the Eagles lose their best player and
when the Super Bowl we saw the Vikings
doing with a backup we've seen Tom Brady
go down and the so teams can survive
without those type of layers and I had
one more example I was gonna bring in
there but I can't remember what it is
now
but either way the the thing I look at
is this offense is still a machine and
it knows how to use that position now
it's not gonna be the same player
Williams right but they'll be able to
move the ball on offense and still be
able to use James Conner and a levy on
belt type away to where I think it'll be
plenty effective now the run game yeah
it'll be there but I don't think it's
gonna be anything special this Browns D
line is pretty damn good they got a lot
of big guys they move around there
create creative with the Greg Williams
sets so I do think the Browns can be a
pain in the butt for the Steelers
offense even if lovey on Bell was out
there I just wouldn't expect them to go
up and down the field no on this defense
so I look at that matchup
now the other matchup is this is where I
get concerned for the Cleveland
Cleveland on the offense side of the
ball you know again I do like their
offensive line
I like their offensive line I do like
that Jarvis Landry I don't think they
have receivers to be scared of we're
gonna see what Josh Gordon saw made that
such a man he is he is the guy that's
the ex we're gonna have our bright light
on like this he's gonna have the same
explosion is he capable of taking over
and I would argue this yeah I would say
that these three guys could be dangerous
for Pittsburgh Josh Gordon David and Joe
ku and Duke Johnson sure three very
athletic guys that are not traditional
receivers yeah that if Todd Haley uses
them well could find holes because
they're all I mean Joe ku and Josh
Gordon or upper lever athletes yeah Duke
is more of a matchup guy he is he said
just the perfect he's not no he's not
gonna like break no tackles and run 70
yards for a touchdown but I think this
is where yes those things are all right
left go and their old line is good but
man this Pittsburgh defense is Tifa it's
real your Super Bowl winners they are
they're my Super Bowl winners not only
for what they have up
run I know the middle linebackers aren't
perfect but I think there's enough there
that I go okay I'm not overly concerned
and the big thing for me with Pittsburgh
this year is I think they're secondary
looks the part for the first time since
maybe 2010 or 2011 where I just go they
got people who can do some extraordinary
things not just play a scheme and sound
who's your pick I am going I'm holding I
gotta go back to mine how much on the
Steelers that's what I'm $10 $10 $10 on
the Steelers that's all I'm going it's
in Cleveland it's a little scary and
Cleveland's I mean they're going for it
they're all in this hall it was like
this can dictate the rest of the season
for them this is the Todd Haley revenge
game right getting a first crack at
these guys also Pittsburgh barely beat
Cleveland I think they won 23 to 20 last
year just like the year right this is
something that I believe in in
Pittsburgh they never get up for one
o'clock road games under Mike Tomlin
against the spread in one o'clock road
games they're 20 and 18 they just they
play down to level they're competition
to the Bears in Chicago the Browns were
in almost every game last year which is
insane that they went Oh in 16 the one
difference they have a quarterback
that's not gonna turn over the ball last
year it was a Kaiser mess-up almost
every game that ruined the spread yeah I
don't think the Steelers offensive line
can push around the Browns d-line I
don't think the Steelers D line is gonna
just get to the quarterback with this
Browns olla right I am putting a hundred
dollars on the Browns to cover the
spread
at home all they gotta do is lose by a
field goal and they still cover I have
faith in tie-rod I think Haley's gonna
go in there and it's gonna take Josh
Gordon to really make it happen
I just could see the Steelers playing
down to the Browns I worried with my bet
that this fighting actually motivates
the Steelers to go let's make James
counter the star that would make my
devil to be what I would bet on I think
it's gonna piss off the whole
organization right now so there yeah I
don't show them that we don't need them
right yeah that's fine but when you
motivate yourself by neck
feelings if it doesn't start going your
way you can turn on yourself very left
doctor left Co so I'm going a hundred
dollars on Cleveland okay I had it on
Pittsburgh and then I was like you know
what I could just see this one being
really tough I'm uh I'm not mad at you
I'm not doing it I am putting a hundred
dollars on the Browns and I get up in
crazy Kansas City at the Chargers an NFC
West battle Chargers enter this game
favored by three and a half they Reese I
know Antonio Gates they have maybe the
best wide receiving corps in the NFL
Kansas City comes in with a depleted
defense that has not looked good and
they've had the worst rushing offense
thus far in the preseason they have a
beautiful young quarterback in Patrick
mahomes they got a lot of weapons and
Kelsey and hunt and of course Ty free
kill Sims we are in a place with hardly
any home field advantage who are you
going with Kansas City at the Chargers
Chargers by three and a half ok charges
by three and a half Horry Legion is out
he is suspended ok so here we go let's
start let's start with that side of the
ball let's start with Kansas City's
offense now it's gonna be the first of
chargers right hey this is this is the
unknown of the matchup I mean really
just right here is just what what do we
think the Kansas City Chiefs are gonna
be on offense here's the unveiling of
this new package under Patrick of
mahomes they're dangerous they're scary
I certainly want to have to deal with it
week one because Andy Reid's amazing as
a game planner he's gonna come up with
stuff that you're gonna go damn we've
never seen that or he's never called
that scheme ever in his life and he
brought it out week one for us we know
there are super talented at the skill
position yeah oh line I do have question
marks about I don't think they're gonna
get like over a run against this
Chargers team but I do worry about it's
Patrick mahomes first start and he's got
Ingram and boast yeah it's the Chargers
Got Talent on the defensive side of the
football and yet it's just
mahomes there's a gunslinger I think
he's gonna have a few moments this year
where we go damn why did he throw that
ball that was stupid but I do have faith
that they're gonna be able to move the
ball and be scary to a degree against
this Chargers defense flipping that side
this is where I get concerned ok for the
Chiefs because I just look
the Chiefs and go I mean they've tried
to sign every guy that's got cut in the
secondary in the NFL on their team
there's obviously concern
the rooted rib or secondary sucks and we
need more players and we're all slot
corners they're all sock corners there's
no lockdown guy
Fuller's good sure we don't know what
the situation is with Barry it doesn't
sound good as he'll is not right and as
he'll is not right that's kind of
important for a sprite free safety yeah
let alone that they don't have really
any big time difference makers upfront
other than our man Jones yes ah Chris
Jones from Mississippi State is going
how much put on the charger so yes
because of that I am going a hundred
dollars on the charges la la super
chargers Diego
[Music]
you know what keep playing that music I
got the Chargers $100 as well la la Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
actually it's everything you said I
agree with in fact I'm not even gonna
expound all right who do you think gets
the most yardage receiving wise running
wise for the Chargers ah okay I think
that the receiver I would be Tyrell
Williams Tyrell William that's who yeah
I think he is the unnamed assassin for
this football team that everybody
forgets and he can find a fill that role
for we have no tight end s you know I
know gates is back in the fold but tyre
Tyrell is that guy that's a little bit
bigger out of the rest of these group to
where I think he works the middle the
field maybe they use him yeah I gotta go
take a piss
I'll be right back okay he just came
back from the bathroom and I just gotta
alert the Falcons are now favored in
this game tonight Wow or last night so
all the late Vegas baby I don't know if
it's late Vegas big money you don't
think so could just be it's been
consistently going Oh has it the Vegas
money comes in like an hour before the
game right so we see like the Falcons
all sudden favored by four then we know
it's gone interesting okay all right
Seattle at Denver Seattle
both teams are rebuilding Seattle has a
whole new look defense chicane Griffin
is starting Denver coming in with Case
Keenum new offensive coordinator how do
you see this one playing out what what
side what matchup you want me to start
with first that's right like when you
tell me let's go russell wilson against
that defense yes that defense that
defense that defense which i think is a
hair overrated okay you hear me I think
the Broncos defense is a hair overrated
after what I saw in the preseason okay
yeah I keep the leaves not there I know
Chris Harris jr. and Bradley Roby are
there but they're not as good as Kristen
I keep deleting from for my money
they're still missing a key part of
their secondary that was awesome for
them that they had three legit cover
corners the last few years their D line
yes it's good I'm not gonna put it in
the great category for one I haven't
necessarily been totally in love with
the late
Miller's look the second half of last
year into this year yeah I think he is a
little too thin like he needs to beef up
a little bit he maybe needs to bless on
the beans and I'll go a little more on
the beef interesting I don't like this
he just looks a little too thin to me
where he's lost a little power in his
game that he used that Bradley chub has
not lived up to the billing yet it's
been solid but that's it there's nothing
where I'm going oh this is got this
might be the best pass rushing duo in
football so I look at that and just go
right now is Von Miller I know they got
Shaquille Barrett and all those other
guys there too but none of them are like
game records to me what about Seattle's
offensive line Seattle's offensive line
is one of the pleasant surprises of
football this year Wow
yes that's the big thing and that's
where I like Schottenheimer they've
gotten away from this Darrell Bevell Ben
McAdoo [ __ ] where it's like we have
two running plays and and did we run the
same two ones every week and yeah we
don't know why that doesn't work I just
I don't know it doesn't work because
everybody knows what you're doing and it
sucks that's why so Schottenheimer yeah
he went to the AFC Championship game
with Mark Sanchez's rookies first and
second year because he was creative in
the run game and with bootlegs and play
actions and made life easier for Russell
right so I look at that and also go
I think the weapons on the Seahawks are
maybe slightly better than I even gave
them credit for I do like the running
back situation I think for shot Penny's
gonna be the man yes we'll see about the
rest of those guys I know penny Carson
right and a Marshall Doug Baldwin driver
lock it all those exactly right I kind
of like that squad how do you see Case
Keenum and that offense tuned against CM
so I again we know this is not the same
Seattle vaunted defense that we've seen
there's no doubt about that but I'm not
gonna sit here I'll sing KJ right it
looks I know okay Jay right and we got
you know the Tasmanian Devil in the
middle and Jimmy Griffin Earl Thomas
just came back he's coming back so that
does help and I don't think he's gonna
be like a huge different maker but I
will say this there's enough on this D
line in Seattle to where I go this isn't
like pushover City up up here to Ron
Reed right Frank Clark exactly right
regime greens in that they got a dion
jordan Heysham are stephen tom johnson
they were good additions from the viking
last year Quentin Jefferson nausea Jones
is a starting defensive tackle for them
so I look at from that standpoint go dim
okay wait I I think they're a little bit
better um so how much you put on the
Seattle seal but so we gotta go then I
go to the other side and yeah I'm just
not totally bought in on the the Broncos
offense yet I gotta see this offensive
line first yeah that that's I haven't
seen it it's better but if he I don't
trust Jarrod Valley er and um you know
Case Keenum you're going big on Seattle
Case Keenum
I do like the way he looked but I don't
love a hundred its Russell Wilson I know
one thing I know is there's one team
that has no theme or no genre to their
team and I know the other team coming
into town it's Russell Wilson and Pete
Carroll and the Seattle Seahawks
Sebastian Janikowski and then you know
like damn we're still good you couldn't
tell them they're not supposed to win
the Superbowl for yeah no no I'm going
on it play that damn music I'm going
$500 on the sea yeah we own drugs we're
in Denver weed is legal Seattle Seahawks
Russell Wilson $500 I like the great
grunge music way to go Nick
so you're taking the two and a half year
ago Seattle I'm gonna I'm gonna put a
hundred on yes this is this is the game
there when you send me your text that
you don't feel good about your this is
your game then he sent his little
eyebrow down and mode you like I don't
know what this is probably the game I'll
eat [ __ ] on and you'll win so I know who
knows
well Holland fendron we have to do a
mascot battle I think this is the one to
do it
you're a Seahawk right I'm a Bronco
right why would a Seahawk beat a Bronco
mean because a Bronco he's too busy and
playing with his rope on his horse and
saying yeehaw and this Seahawk just
comes down with his talents yeah and
it's a cute little Bronco he's nice as a
white Bronco but man this Seahawk comes
down and first of all the Talon goes
right into the guy riding the horse
I don't leave there's no human any oh no
humans involved okay then he just goes
my heart misses and the Bronco just
begins to trample the Seahawk
incessantly stomping the life out of the
little bird coming from the Pacific
coast welcome to Mountain Time welcome
to the naysayers of the Bronco the Ox
don't stumble they don't do that they
have reversible talons as josh has
taught us to so he's gonna be able to
grab that throat of that little horsie
gonna want to reverse Europe and it's
over no I'm not yes this is where we do
it well I feel really bad about that
I just couldn't buy it yeah I just think
people are sleeping on the Seahawks a
little bit I think you're right and I
actually think I'm wrong on this I think
I what I was gonna try and switch my
pick it is freakin Russell Wilson and
Pete Carroll and they I just I just
think they will say this though Seattle
starts every season slow a little slow
and that's I think that's the reason I
went with it because I think Seattle was
gonna start slow and I went you know
what I think Denver's gonna have some
stuff up their sleeve yeah I don't that
I think that's what I feel least
confident about okay good and by the way
Denver has won their home opener the
last six years uh doodle is Dallas at
Carolina no Thomas Davis David Irving is
suspended Travis Frederick is out
Carolina is favored by three Carolina
Carolina favored by three yes this is
I'm excited to watch this football game
I have no idea what's gonna happen this
is too big physical football teams I
think that's the thing that jumps out to
me more than anything I'm pulling up the
roster just so I don't forget anything
sorry I have to do it because I don't
feel comfortable unless I do it alright
I'm gonna give my pick gun I am going
100 dollars on Dallas plus three okay I
that's incredible I I wish that Dallas
had more of their playmakers playing on
their D line I really want David Irving
to be out there but I do have faith in
DeMarcus Lawrence and what we're seeing
out of Randy Gregory right here I have a
lot of fear in Christian McCaffrey
because I I don't think that the
linebackers Shawn Lee and Jaylon Smith
can really match his speed
okay but I look at the d-line of the
Panthers and I go they're gonna make it
hard for the Cowboys
I really do with with who they have
there with the D line come on short you
thank you sorry and they have not load -
lele oh yeah Don tarapoto oh right but I
do think that they're gonna wear them
down and I do think that Dallas is gonna
keep running and I do think not having
Thomas Davis could be an issue my only
fear Carolina wants to play in the box
they love playing in the box it's like
how that fort like that franchise was
built it does scare me I'm just going
with Dallas cuz I think that there are
there going to be a better football team
this year I know I'm going out on a limb
there but I'm putting a hundred on
Dallas I'm on that limb with you with
the Dallas Cowboys I mean I think
they're gonna be a better football team
this this games just got too many ifs
for me to put too much money on this I'm
going $10 on the Cowboys just so you
have your yep I'm gonna do $10 but it
does scare me yeah cowboy we ridin into
Carolina I'm gonna rope us a Carolina
Panther but I think the big thing is
there's just too many unknowns it is a -
physical football team so we're not
trying to reinvent the wheel on what
they do want either side of the football
I think what I do like about the Dallas
Cowboys their D line is deep I think
their secondary is very good and I know
there's safety there they could probably
use another piece there but the three
cover corners they got I like them their
ability to match up with the Carolina
Panthers I think they're big enough and
physical enough up front to stop the run
game of the Carolina Panthers the
Carolina Panthers old line is not gonna
be bad that sounds like Darrell Williams
is gonna be that it does now he might
not be totally 100% for a week 1 so I
played that into account that Carolina's
offense will not be hitting on all
cylinders because I don't think their
old line will be and I do think this
Cowboys defense is pretty special now
you go to the other side of the ball and
I just go real quick I go hey the
Cowboys ol line we know what's special
that negates some of the power and the
ability of the Carolina Panthers just to
steamroll them there's no great pass
rusher on the Carolina Panthers I think
that's what scares me more of an
interior rush right that's the weakness
it could be rally and center exactly
Williams playing guard also be someone
to watch our that's something to watch
out you're sure I'm afraid of too is
it's not Daniel it's not they have a new
kicker for the DA Bailey's not there
damn Bailey's gone sure
so there's too many ifs there that's
what I'm just saying that's why I
couldn't do $100 I know it's because of
what main reason I'm signing with Dallas
just because I do think that they're the
better football team right now it's what
I do and I think uh zekiel Elliott's
poised for a special year and I think
that we haven't seen what this Dallas
offense is gonna be I just have a weird
inkling reading the tea leaves knowing
some people in the world that Dallas has
not uncorked their offense III don't
think so we haven't even seen but I mean
they've been talking about Tavon Austin
you're I think you're gonna have a role
legit role for him I think their
receivers are a little undervalued I
think they're all solid and no superstar
no great but all can do the same thing
to where you couldn't put a beat on them
to go they do this with this guy and
that would that guy know they can all do
all of those that's why I go to Cowboys
Washington at Arizona Markus golden
missed practice Robert Kim D G Corey
Peters have been limited for Arizona
Arizona is favored by one at home this
is a four o'clock game it's the last
four o'clock game yeah how do you see
this one play now uh I think this would
be a close football game Arizona's
offense it's been somewhat encouraging
but I still worry about their old line
especially against this group this we've
talked about it this Redskins D lines
real they can they can ruin games for
football teams and I think that does
scare me still I expect like I said a
little bit of a better run game with
David Johnson back Mike McCoy being the
OC there I do think they'll be patient
with the run and try to work that aspect
I just don't know whether there are
enough weapons on the outside to really
scare the Redskins secondary ok and then
I flip it over and go man I mean so what
those guys are as none of them are
special I mean that's what I mean I just
there's too many unknowns on the Arizona
defense that's also making a total
scheme regime change where there's some
things I like don't get me wrong I mean
Chandler Jones the man Patrick Peterson
Buchanan right and we'll see we'll see
how they use our our first-round pick
last year
ridic I think mines gonna be in that
Thomas Davis type of role for this
defense but because of that and lack of
other impressive defensive linemen on
Arizona I go with Washington I think
Washington's a lot of one of those teams
again like we talked about getting a
point getting a point I think they're
going to win the football game it is on
the road in Arizona and scared me that's
why I only go ten dollars on the skins I
am going 100 dollars on the Washington
I feel very similar that the way I feel
about Cleveland Alex Smith is going to
protect the ball yeah I am very excited
to see a healthy Jordan read a healthy
Chris Thompson I don't know if Paul
Richardson I don't know if Josh
dachshunds involved but the fact that
Washington has Jordan Reed Chris
Thompson and Jameson Crowder with a
quarterback like Alex Smith and an
offensive line that is a top-five
offensive line that everyone forgets
against a smaller Arizona team that's
what I like I think Washington might
actually win this one comfortably I
wanted to go hard in this game you
didn't because I I just because I don't
know I don't think Washington has that
killer instinct I don't know what they
are and I don't know an Alex Smith right
I just got to see the abhinav ski on
defense my whole philosophy was a factor
week one if I F factor if there was too
many ifs I stayed away from it no I
didn't put a lot of money on the
Chargers yeah because I don't like
facing Andy Reid with extended time
that's why I didn't kiss that's an if
for me it's an if I know I put $100 on
the Chargers I was know yeah yeah it's
alright I get it that scared the [ __ ]
out of me too I was more playing the
factor of I think the Chargers are the
better team and I don't trust my home's
there and that meant forgot Seattle's
your big bet yeah all right let's go to
Sunday Night Football
Sony night Aaron Rodgers against the
Khalil Mack led Chicago Bears Sims what
are you doing the Packers are favored at
home by seven and a half the second
largest line of the week like this pop
to me I mean absolutely popped
the Bears so let's just go on the
offensive side of the ball first with
the Packers which the Bears defense the
Bears front seven is arguably one of the
best in the sport their middle
linebackers ro Quan Smith and Danny
Trevathan like yeah okay have fun with
that good luck that's that's a
phenomenal front seven let alone Leonard
Floyd and Khalil Mack and Akeem Hicks
and Eddie Goldman and Jonathan Bullard
and I don't know I'm forgetting other
ones that are involved in this oh my man
Roy Robertson Harris who's a
newly-formed beast in the middle of that
defense I just look at them and go uh
you know Aaron Rodgers gonna have to win
the game with his passing and just do
the same old like Aaron Rodgers crap and
do I think he can win the game that way
of course I do but by seven and a half
points what I think that's freaking
crazy I do
I mean first thing to is the secondary
matchups I mean the Bears secondary who
love Eddie Jackson you love fuller
I love fuller fuller is going to be a
top five corner in the sport this year
Adrian Amos is very good I'm not ready
to put him into star stratosphere yet
but he's very good Prince Amukamara is
solid on the other side and they have
some other solid guys then I go to the
other side of the ball okay what are we
gonna get from Nagy's offense against
this patent deal let's talk about it
right I mean we know we both I think
think the Bears old line is pretty damn
good we think Nagy's pretty creative we
got weapons all over the weapons all
over the place I don't even know we know
already red Davis yes right almost too
many weapons and added the fact that yes
I'm more positive about the Packers
defense but I'm not ready to sit here
and just go they're gonna shut down the
you know every team they play and it's
gonna be that type of defense no I don't
see it that way I still think the
Packers lacked depth and lack some
big-time different makers in their front
seven they have improved the secondary
but I don't think enough to do it so I
am putting $500 on the Chicago Bears
[Music]
I hate Packers I eat people who put
paper bags on their head or paper bags
on things the Packer is I don't know
maybe cheese
I think Packers have cheese I know but I
yeah they pack something away I don't
know dangerous that was really dangerous
I mind when the gutter I am putting $100
on the Bears okay I definitely had this
as Green Bay for a little bit and then I
went back to the Bears I'm with you the
thing that scares me Green Bay has a
history of beating the crap out of the
Bears at home yeah it's just like what
they do even when we're confident about
them and I know I'm excited like I look
at the Bears roster when holy crap they
have Taylor Gabriel and I forgot about
it now Robinson and Kevin white and Evan
Miller Anthony Miller and even Javon
whims but like Taylor Gabriel could
catch a ball and go 70 I know that we
like the Bears offensive line I'm not a
huge fan of Eric cush at left guard okay
and I I do I don't think they're over I
don't think they're a powerful offensive
line I think they're a good offensive
they're right and I do go man if Rogers
like do you think that Jamal Williams
and and they're good Packers to be able
to run on the Bears or no I think it's
gonna be I think should be just [ __ ] I
think it'll be very tough sledding I
don't think it's gonna know the big runs
of the night will be Aaron Rodgers
escaping the pocket and making runs that
way yeah I worry about Aaron Rodgers
just kind of making a few big plays and
figuring it out but I just think the
Bears defense should be able to keep it
tight seven and a half this to me was
like a three and a half four and a half
not a seven and I I would agree also I
look at how Fangio did you know in years
against the Packers when he was with the
49ers they can slow them down I mean
he's done that he gave Aaron Rodgers one
of his worst playoff performances ever
yeah this is one thing where you know
I'm picking the Packers to win the game
but man people don't be shocked if we
wake up Monday morning Chicago's won
this game
it's just I feel like there's no profits
there's no offense more hyped than the
Bears offense and we need to see it
quick we do especially because like true
Biscay didn't play at the end no I don't
have preseason I um Monday Night
Football
sandé Arnold our best buddy going to
Detroit take it on Matt Patricia
and the Lions are favored by six and a
half yes what were you going here well
that's a lot of points for a Lions team
that I have questions about awful yes
it's awful are you going Jets I'm going
$10 on the jet I'm going $100 yes I I
don't know if I can sit here and pick
the Jets to win the football game I'm
gonna pick Detroit to win the football
game but I do think it's gonna be close
I mean that scares me from a Jets
perspective is a lack of a big pass rush
against Matt stature they have the
secondary to cover they do but how long
are they gonna have to cover people I
know the thing that excites me from a
Jets perspective I think the Detroit
Lions want to run the ball and the Jets
are not one of those teams where you
really want to try and push it a lot of
big people a lot of big tip right
Leonard Williams Steve McClendon they're
ready for you yeah and their linebackers
can be all over the place yes again I
think that's that Sam the question is is
Sam gonna turn over the ball or is he
gonna protect the ball right cuz
sometimes he gets a little crafty and I
get a little bit worried and I do think
that the Lions have a few big weapons to
take advantage but I thought that the
Lions d-line has been getting pushed
around thus far that's it's that would
be playing to my factor here and there's
again this is a game I look at 20
pounding Isaiah Crowell and Bilal Powell
III could I love a noon walk across the
middle right I mean we haven't seen the
Jets make big-time plays in their past
game yet we need to see that but yeah
this is not Alliance defense that is
special by any stretch of the
imagination there's not a huge lot of
huge difference makers and I do think
they're still in the process of figuring
out the rules of the map patrícia
defense you know it there's a lot of
rules to that defense Bill Belichick and
what they do up there that's why they're
kind of bend don't break all the time
and they play it conservative and they
don't just let their deal I'm and pin
their ears back and get after people I
am expecting the Lions the win just
because Matt Stafford will make enough
plays to win this football
but I think this is a very close game
when all said and done like like lions
win twenty four twenty or twenty three
seventeen something wrong along those
lines
Rams at Oakland yeah Rams are favored by
four yeah clearly the better football
team
they just haven't played at all this
many season that's this was the line
that everyone's coming to me and going
you got a bet on the Rams and there's
just something about it I could see
halftime the Raiders being up ten three
and like what's going on with the Rams
and people are freaking out just because
they haven't gotten any reps they could
also come out and be up 21 to 3 very
well could be ah yeah would you go with
what I'm going with the Rams but only
$10 I went a hundred on the Rams you've
been 100 on the ranch man man yeah
doesn't matter that we didn't play I'm
yeah I do I do worry about the things
that you just mentioned up I mentioned
that certainly cancer such a more
talented football team at literally
every position a really except quarter
and but also the other thing we have to
end off is good Jared Goff is good uh
the rest of the team is really good it's
one of the best rosters in the sport I
think the thing that scares me is like
you said they didn't play and we don't
know what Gurdon is about - um you think
he's gonna uncork something I'd be
better after this frickin well I would
think so and the fact that hey their
faces way maps I know it's his first
game back - then the and the Coliseum is
gonna be bonkers yeah but that's where I
think you're gonna bow John and I like
that way yes okay I think that it's
gonna be bonkers but it's gonna be
everywhere if that offense starts slow
the boos are raining down
I think Gruden has already lost the fan
base yeah that's what happens when you
trade away the best player for two
first-round picks and you're not good at
drafting yeah and you're losing the team
in two years so you've mortgaged the now
for the future and they don't even get
to experience the future I think that
the I think that the Coliseum could turn
on Gruden fast where's the pass rush
come from the Raiders don't know right
you know who the cover corners what did
we don't we don't know Gary and Conley
we haven't seen him yet okay we're going
DRC and also the older guys
faced it yeah you think that Gruden's
gonna in quark something you don't think
that Sean McVeigh does this former coach
is going let me show you who the new
Gruden is yeah I do
I know I know that's I would I just to
see the Rams not executing the way they
should
of course like a like golf missing some
easy throws or maybe even Gurley
fumbling just because he hasn't been hit
since last year's wild-card game
those are the things that scared me
there's no doubt who the better team on
the field is all right so let me recap
these the main ones that meet we
disagreed on we disagreed un Atlanta I
went Philadelphia
you went Jacksonville I went the Giants
you went San Francisco
I went Minnesota you went Pittsburgh I
took the points with Cleveland UN
Seattle big I went Denver your biggest
bets 200 on Atlanta 100 on Miami 100 on
Cincinnati 100 on the Chargers 500 on
Seattle 500 on Chicago go Aaron Rodgers
go Case Keenum I am pretty sure right
now I'm gonna make my left Cole ox okay
Baltimore -7 Miami + 1 and a half
Cincinnati + 3 Andy Reid scares me and
that's why I'm not putting more money on
the Chargers I know I like I like your
thing in Seattle I'm not gonna go and
I'm not going Dallas
so I Chicago is interesting I don't feel
like betting against Aaron Rodgers when
I know they have a guy that just started
and ro Quan Smith's a rookie so there's
just a little bit thing and Green Bay as
a history so I think I'm gonna go Ravens
against Buffalo I'm taking advantage of
Nathan Peterman yeah Miami against
Tennessee it's a home hot Miami and I
can't believe that you're getting points
there and then Cincinnati its Andrew
Luck for the first time in a year I'm
taking what I believe are the more
talented roster support that I do that's
totally support those will be my three
teams you'll see those and a left go LOX
graphic they'll probably all get blown
out and then everyone will tell me I am
an
before we go it's a segment that we'd
hate to leave out it is guaranteed to
lose no spreads just five teams at Sims
has they're gonna lose guaranteed to
lose here we go first up oh it's an old
familiar flow follow I should say I'm
out of my flow Oh Buffalo Bills
welcome to guaranteed to lose you know
why you're gonna lose cuz I said so and
this is my damn segment and I'll say
what the hell goes on but you're
starting Nathan Peterman against the
Baltimore Ravens it's the top one of the
toughest stadiums to play for and Nathan
Peterman has no weapons
sorry Buffalo circle the wagons some
other time who's second okay second is
Tampa Bay Buccaneers
oh no welcome to New Orleans I don't
think pirate ships can fit up through
the canals in New Orleans so you're
stuck you're in a bad spot and it's Drew
Brees versus Ryan Fitzpatrick ah yes
sorry drew Brees greater is Ryan
Fitzpatrick next character lives
I'm so sorry Jimmy Q Jimmy GQ and the
49ers but you're gonna lose to the
Minnesota Vikings why because
Minnesota's better on both sides of the
ball I think no Jimmy but not Kyle
Shanahan sorry girls our friendship
fractured very much
oh I gots to seize it to believes it's
Cleveland Browns welcome back for these
thirty third week in a row yes there I'm
not taking them off the list until they
win more than one game a year and they
got the mad angry pittsburgh steelers
coming to town you will lose left goes
mom said you're gonna lose a you lose
Sharon is the ball team guaranteed to
lose this team this is a tough one but
Kansas City oh honey you're gonna go to
the Los Angeles chargers and yes there's
no home-field advantage but it's a
rookie quarterback making his first
start against the bro Graham and Bosa
and Ingram and Philip Rivers I think is
an MVP candidate this year and the chief
secondary have you seen it lately no
neither have I because it stinks and
you're gonna lose
and that is school guaranteed to lose so
if you're doing a survival pool the fire
bathra the five teams that Sims thinks
are guaranteed to lose the bills at the
Ravens Tampa at New Orleans San
Francisco at Minnesota Cleveland hosting
the Steelers Kansas City at the chargers
out of those I'm most confident in
Buffalo yeah Buffalo so if you're doing
a survivor pool Sims is giving you those
five teams however you want to navigate
right as the five teams he things are
most likely to lose yes sir
how do you feel about your picks overall
I feel pretty good I do it's funny here
I was not confident about my picks and
we really only disagreed on five of them
right and I'm okay with them because I
know in your heart you wanted to take
Minnesota and the Giants um yes but I
only paid ten dollars so I don't care
I'm gonna make my big bet Seahawks and
the Chicago Bears all right so I get to
root for Aaron Rodgers and I'm ruining
against Seattle that will hurt me
because I love Russell Wilson with all
my heart yeah guys those are our picks
again if you watch the show on Wednesday
night when you're watching games on
Sunday and you see a penalty that should
not have been called or was too
excessive use the hashtag keep it in
your pocket in your pitch we're talking
about your flags keep it in your pants
talking about flags and we're gonna
continue this conversation I will be on
social on Sims aleko we're gonna have a
good time we're gonna have Sims kind of
doing some videos maybe tweeting in some
stuff oh god and it's gonna be great
we love you guys we hope that your team
wins unless it's against another fan
that supports us more you lose for Sims
peace out homey Patrick would say good
evening and the lef koe man holla holla
holla holla holla holla holla can you
believe the Eagles won last night